MAN: Time to get things
Right now what I want to do is
work on the roof of my shelter
to make sure it's
nice and strong,
because when I have
three feet of snowfall,
I do not want a flimsy tarp
being the only thing holding up
the roof.
I need to add some skeletal
infrastructure to it,
so that it can take a little bit
of weight when the time comes.
Unfortunately, my bowels are
still not kicking anything out.
I'm getting worried,
because I'm having really
bad issues with my intestines.
Feels like I've got stomach
cramping and abdominal pain.
The rules of this
thing are simple.
If you ask for help from the
crew, you have tapped out.
They can't come in and give
me a laxative and be like,
there you go, bud,
anything else?
They absolutely
have to either wait
for me to tap out,
or medically pull
me, or wait for me to poop.
So that sits real
nicely up on there.
I never, in my
wildest imagination,
thought that one poop
could get in the way
from my family having a
house and a car that doesn't
break down, but it just has.
So at the moment, I'm basically
finished with this ceiling.
Anytime I'm cutting little, thin
saplings and I get a new one,
I can just interweave it, and
it's just going to get stronger
and stronger as we go along.
So I love it.
I'm going to keep it this way.
The only thing in my head
right now is the fact
that if I don't go to
the bathroom-- like,
if I don't have a bowel
movement in the next few days,
I'm going to be medically
pulled, and I won't get to win,
and I won't get to
provide for my family.
I feel like I've put in
so much work out here.
I feel like I want to
make it the long haul.
I don't want to have to go
home from this empty-handed.